all right people
how you doing everybody it is november
10th
tuesday november 10th we are one week
to the day from the election it seems
like it either happened five minutes ago
or a lifetime
ago depending on uh your outlook on life
but it is one week ago uh we sort of
have a result kinda have a result we
have a result if you like the result we
don't have a result if you don't like
the result
that and much more on today's direct
message i'm in a good mood this morning
i have an absolutely packed
day today i just did an interview with
the epic times they came here
and we shot something in studio i'm
going to be on dana perino
right after this on fox news i was on
oan this morning we got a couple other
things going on
just a lot it's a lot and it's all good
i wake
up i've got something to do i hope you
do as well uh today
the three stories that we're going to be
covering i suspect you've heard
about at least two of them already and
then the third one is just a hilarious
bananas
uh media meltdown story but first we're
going to be talking about mitch
mcconnell you know mitch mcconnell the
man looks like a turtle but he
acts like a lion uh
he is not going to be listening to
the democrats who are saying that you
guys better be nice now
because uh you lost um and he
is ready to go all cocaine mitch up in
here
as they say so we'll play a little video
from mitch mcconnell we'll talk about
that
uh then of course the the big news today
that really should supersede everything
else although you're not going to see
much
about it on mainstream media because it
doesn't fit the narrative
um is that the department of justice is
going to probe quote
substantial allegations of voting
irregularities this is from attorney
general
barr and we will see what happens
as i said yesterday regardless if you
wanted biden to win or trump to win what
you should want
is a feeling of integrity in the system
you should want
any legal recourse to take its action
to you know go to the end and then you
would want
all parties whether it's trump or biden
to abide by
whatever the outcome is so again the
results of the election have not been
certified
technically joe biden is not the
president-elect the media has said that
he is
uh there are some interesting things
coming out of michigan and arizona and
everything
where else i am not trying to send you
guys down a spiral of conspiracy
theories i'm just talking
about what i'm seeing and unfortunately
that the mainstream media
isn't covering most of it so we'll dive
into that and then third uh there's a
video going viral right now that's
absolutely hilarious
from msnbc when one of their
correspondents
he said some dirty words something
happened and he said some dirty words
and it's and it's just funny when these
robotic people that we watch on
mainstream
when you actually see that they are
truly humans
or at least part humans something like
that uh so we'll play that
but before we get to any of it people
are you looking for a new protein bar
that tastes like a candy bar
well if so i've got just the brand
for you and i'm holding it in my hand
built bars right here they're super
tasty they come in 18 amazing flavors my
personal favorite as you know
is the cookies and cream bill bars are
covered in 100
chocolate include both nut and nut free
flavors and are soft
and easy to chew with the holidays just
around the corner it's easy to slip
up which is why build bars are the
perfect alternative to pie
for the health conscious guy i can
actually lose or maintain weight while
indulging in a delicious treat built
bars are low calorie low sugar high
protein and high fiber
go to billboard.com and use promo code
ruben and you'll get 20
off your first order use promo code
ruben for 20
off at builtbar.com good for bars built
go
or build boost and now back to me
all right so let's talk about the state
of politics right now you know i
promised you when i started this show
that i wasn't going to get into the
nitty-gritty of every little political
fight
because i think that's part of the
problem that we are all so
obsessed with every little thing that
happens politically
as if every little thing that happens
politically is going to affect our lives
and a good government
would be nice and tight and you could
fit it in a little box you could wrap it
in a bow and you could put it aside
because it wouldn't have that much power
over your lives that being said
sometimes there are stories politically
that do matter and i think the
the story that matters right now well of
course you've got the the results of the
election but then we do also have what's
happening with the house and the senate
and it is important
to know because you know when the
founders set up this crazy system that
we have
they gave us three branches of
government and they can check each other
and they can balance each other out and
that makes
it so that nobody can be too powerful
and we don't end up living under a king
which is a good thing at least from
where i sit so let's take a look at this
video this is from c-span
this is mitch mcconnell uh pushing back
on the idea that republicans need to be
lectured to now
about civility and how to how to take a
loss and
and the whole damn thing mitch now more
broadly mr
president let's not have any lectures
no lectures about how the president
should immediately
cheerfully accept preliminary election
results
from the same characters who just spent
four years refusing to accept the
validity of the last election
and who insinuated that this one
would be illegitimate too
if they lost again only if they lost
so let's have no lectures on this
subject from that contention
in late august secretary hillary clinton
said quote
joe biden should not concede under any
circumstances
i think this is going to drag out and he
will win it
if we don't give an inch
that same month speaker pelosi and the
democratic leader both stated quote
president trump needs to cheat to win
in october when speaker pelosi was
shopping some conspiracy theory about
the postal service
she recklessly said quote listen to this
i have no doubt that the president will
lie
cheat and steal to win the election
now does this sound like a chorus that
has
any credibility whatsoever to say a few
legal challenges from president trump
represent some kind of crisis
all right people so what did mitch
mcconnell do there what did he just do
he used quotes he used actual quotes
things that people like hillary clinton
and nancy pelosi have said
over the past couple years about what
happened last time and what's going to
happen this time
i should also add that hillary clinton
has repeatedly said in interviews over
the last four years that the election
was
stolen from her okay those are her words
so now suddenly the same people who for
four years didn't accept the results of
the election let's not forget we had
basically two years of a russian
collusion hoax that
led to an impeachment scam
and we were told we have to believe this
stuff okay
and that we shouldn't even question
whether it's true or not we have to
believe it
i want to tell you a personal story in
the midst of all of this because back in
december when impeachment was just
heating up
i did i gave a talk one morning at uh
at a turning point usa event and then
that night and you've probably heard me
talk about this
i actually had dinner with uh trump jr
david and i had dinner with trump jr and
kimberly guilfoyle
at mar-a-lago i know they're supposed to
be big homophobes and i'm sure the place
doesn't let in gay people but
okay it was all good we had dinner and
and trump now remember this is the
middle of impeachment it had just
started taking off you know it was
probably a week or two in
something like that and trump is sitting
there in the room we're one table away
from trump
and uh giuliani was there a couple other
people were there he was sitting next to
the first lady
and every story that day was the walls
are closing in
they're coming for trump paranoia in the
white house
he knows he's guilty we're going to take
him out in chains
i was looking at trump he was literally
eight feet away from me he had no tie on
which is weird to see him without a tie
because he's always got the tie
his hair was like the end of the day so
his hair was like a little lower than
usual kind of floppier than usual
and he was laughing up a storm this was
in the middle of the
the impeachment thing okay now i mention
that
because the point is it seems to me that
he knew
that he didn't do anything and that it
was going to come out to be a scam which
is exactly
what it did that doesn't mean you have
to love trump it just is what it is
so the point that mcconnell is making is
that these people the mainstream media
the democratic establishment
they have lied to us for years because
they didn't accept the results of the
election they did everything they could
to undermine the last election
now they seemingly got what they want
and now you're not allowed to question
anything which is why
cnn and the new york times and
everywhere else is just constantly
telling us there's no proof of anything
now we don't know if there's proof of
anything there's been some interesting
things
that we're seeing on twitter right we're
seeing
some evidence of something but if you
guys won't even
show us that right if you just dismiss
it right
tapper jake tapper and stelter and the
rest of these guys if you just dismiss
it
and and ignore it instead of showing
people why don't you just debunk it but
they won't do that they won't do that
because they think it'll give it energy
but ironically what that does they're
they're ignoring of of the stories
that are coming out of michigan and
coming out of pennsylvania and
everywhere else
whether they're true or not or whether
they're widespread or not or if they're
enough of anything to cause a reversal
of a result or anything like that when
they ignore it the average
person that sees these stories goes wait
a minute it does seem like something
here
suddenly 10 000 votes showed up provided
i don't know it seems like a little
something
and they're ignoring it so it's like oh
well then maybe something is there
because i don't trust the mainstream
media and in many ways
this election is far more about distrust
in the mainstream media than
than anything else so the last thing
that i'll say on this real quick
is that it's odd to see someone like
mitch mcconnell who comes off as you
know he's very quiet and you know he's
got he actually has some health issues
which is a little bit of
explain some of his posture and
everything else
but he has actually come out to be
someone that seems pretty principled in
this
he's not saying you don't accept the
results of the election and by the way i
haven't seen anyone
say you don't accept the results of the
election of course you say accept the
results of the election
but let's call out the hypocrisy and
let's let
the system go through the processes
so that at the end you know what if it
turns out that the votes aren't there
i guarantee you trump's going to walk
what is he going to do he's going to
hold up
in the white house and and the military
is going to defend him like no that's
that's not how it's going to work um but
the idea that somehow we have to be nice
right now and they ha
and they're you know they're reaching
out
and we have to be nice after what they
just did like i'm all for reaching out i
think i've tried to do this show to
build bridges and the rest of it
but we have to understand the hypocrisy
when we see it
but before i get to story number two i
want to talk to you guys about top
resume because we just did some hiring
here at the reuben report our businesses
are blowing up
because you know what we're doing
something decent with today's high
employment rates and uncertain future
it's hard to plan ahead
yet alone look for a new job here at the
reuben report we understand that that
struggle is real and as i said we just
finished hiring a new position and
realize very quickly how important it is
to have a resume that stands out among
the rest when it comes to writing your
own resume there's an unlimited number
of things that can go wrong and the cost
of those mistakes can be a missed
opportunity
to secure your dream job top resume is
the world's premier resume writing
service writing and analyzing more than
four million resumes and linkedin
profiles every year
top resumes professional writers will
create a resume that showcases your
talents achievements
experience and career goals using
keywords and skills that recruiters
are seeking top resume also offers a
free resume critique service including
confidential comprehensive review from
trusted experts
objective feedback on how well your
resume communicates your skills
and expertise and personalized
recommendations on how to make your
resume stronger
go to the pros to get the job done right
let the experts at top resume work with
you to create a job winning resume that
gets noticed
find out how to get your find out how
your resume stacks up go to
com slash topresuming.com to get a free
resume review it's as simple as
uploading your resume to their site and
you'll get a free evaluation and expert
advice on how to make it stronger
top resume is also giving my listeners
15 off
their professional resume writing
services so go to topresume.com
ruben today for your comprehensive
resume review
and 15 off resume review writing
services
if you want to work with a pro that's
top resume dot com slash reuben
and now back to me all right so attorney
general
bob barr as they're saying on the
twitter he's been activated
so what is happening right now well the
department of justice and that's
the department that the attorney general
is in charge of he
is now decided to do a probe to
quote check the substantial allegations
of voting irregularities so let me get
you the the exact quote because
i'm a hell of a journalist apparently
even though i don't consider myself a
journalist
this is bob barr he said i'm sorry this
is from the associated press
the trump administration through the
presidential transition
into tumult on monday attorney general
william
barr authorizing the justice department
to probe allegations of voter fraud and
president donald trump
firing the pentagon chief and blocking
government officials from cooperating
with president-elect joe biden's team
okay so to basically unpack this
bob barr you may remember the video
maybe we'll even cover this tomorrow
you know we will cover this tomorrow uh
there's a video from i think it's about
two or three months ago where bob barr
was being uh it was a bob barr it's bill
barr
it's bill barr bill barr i got built
bars
and i got bill bar i keep calling him
bob barr bill barr
sorry guys there's a video from about
two months ago when bill
barr william bill barr was on cnn and he
was being interviewed
by wolf blitzer about voter fraud and
voter irregularities and what he would
do
and how male and ballots are changing
things and and offer more
uh room for malfeasance and all of that
and there's a really interesting clip
it's probably about a minute or two
we'll play it tomorrow
uh so that you can actually see the clip
but he was warning that there could be
fraud and of course there can be fraud
in any election i suspect if some of the
things that we're seeing right now
we saw in some election in eastern
europe say ukraine or some election
in north africa that we might say oh
maybe something weird went there and the
media would be running with it if
if the media didn't get the result that
they wanted so in essence
what bill barr is doing who's bob barr i
don't know who bob barr is wasn't there
was there a democratic politician named
bob barr a long time ago he kind of
looked like a mouse he had a little
mustache can we google
bob barr i think there was a guy named
bob barr but in any essence
in any event bill barr uh
is going billbar it's a really bill barr
right there um they're gonna look into
it
now that doesn't mean that they're gonna
do anything and by the way by looking
into it
that would then if you've got 70 million
people who are just going you know
something ain't quite right and we don't
trust the
mainstream media well then looking into
it letting things go to the courts where
then
you know it's very hard to fake the data
i actually have talked to a couple
experts on this and a couple people
really in the know about elections and
what
virtually everyone has said to me is
it's very very hard to fake the data in
a way that wouldn't be obvious if you're
faking it
so by the justice department looking
into
these allegations well then they'll get
the papers in front of them they're
going to look at the numbers and then
they have all sort of math equations and
everything else that they can look and
they can see
is there something really wacky here
like did a hundred thousand votes
show up at 3am for one candidate nothing
for the other candidate that would be
odd
but they know what they're looking for
and letting the justice department
look at this i think is absolutely
completely fine
and then by the way as i just said at
the end you get to the end of it
and at the end they go you know what we
didn't find anything we did not find
anything
or we found some things that were
inconsequential or maybe we found
some stuff in one state that's not
enough to change the results of the
election
or whatever it is well then you've let
the process play out
but what i'm seeing right now from a lot
of people
a lot of people sort of in the skeptic
community and generally people who are
who are sort of um i would say skeptical
of power
suddenly everyone's saying no we can't
look at anything we can't look at
anything and that's what the mainstream
media is pushing
on you and that's what twitter will
censor and everything else so
all of these things i mean again all of
the things that we always talk about
here they all sort of whittle
into how are you as a person
supposed to figure out what is true in
the mix of this
and the answer to that is it is freaking
difficult it is just really difficult to
do
because we've got a media that ignores
stuff we've got a media that pushes
stuff
and it's all dependent on on who's in
power as i talked about with the
previous story
but speaking of our mainstream media i
saw this
video this morning on msnbc this just
went viral about an hour ago and i
i said to my producer michael this
morning you know i don't want to just
drub everybody
with politics today you guys know i try
not to do that in general but i wanted
to find something like a little more
lighthearted or silly or offbeat
or whatever now this is msnbc so it is
sort of
political but i think you're going to
see why i thought this clip would be
just right
to end the show today this is msnbc this
is craig melvin
is uh is interviewing uh a reporter
by the name of ken delanian and uh well
take a look has some new reporting on
something that we talked about at the
top of the hour
how the trump administration is handling
the transition with the incoming biden
team or
not handling it we should say to a
certain extent this time
it involves our intelligence community
uh ken what have you learned sir
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
okay uh think we lost think we lost ken
for a second we'll try to
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
the media just became self-aware you see
that ken
ken what have you learned about this
thing that we're constantly
talking about [ __ ] [ __ ]
um i don't know exactly what happened
there and i'm gonna i don't know who ken
is i've never seen ken before but i'm
gonna give ken
the benefit of the doubt that maybe
something weird happened with his ifb
that's the little thing
that you put in your ear so that you can
actually hear the feed like i have it in
my ear right now not so that someone can
tell me what to say or anything like
that but so that i could hear the clip
right so i could hear that
msnbc clip because we can't play it
through my speakers in here because
i've got a microphone on and it causes
reverb and a whole bunch of other things
so i'm going to guess that maybe
something happened some weird crackling
or something
but there's just something sort of
beautiful about like
you know watching craig melvin's you
know in effect like
so we we don't know what the hell is
going on trump
may acknowledge something may not
acknowledge
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] like
it's just perfect and there's also
something about you know i talk about
this a lot
about like seeing these mainstream media
people
that in fact they are human you know you
only see them in the little box right
and they act very serious all the time
and
you know they're very self-righteous and
very moral and you know they've got
their
their glasses and the rest of it and yet
the truth is that they are people
you know breaking news
it's like i think that's why so many
people
are just tuning out of this because the
the act
we've we've sort of seen through the act
you know what i mean we've pulled the
curtain aside
and it's not the great wizard of oz it's
just you know this little guy
this little nervous scientist like that
that's sort of where we're at
with everything right now so it's just
it's you know what let's play the clip
again
can we connor can we get that thing
going again i i need to see it
one more time i i said i've got a busy
day today but i feel like this will set
me up right
so let's throw to the clip one more time
this is
ken delanian responding to craig melvin
on ms nbc has some new reporting on
something that we talked about
at the top of the hour how the trump
administration
is handling the transition with the
incoming biden team
or not handling it we should say to a
certain extent
this time it involves our intelligence
community
uh ken what have you learned sir oh [ __ ]
[ __ ]
okay uh i think we lost
i mean the way that craig oh you know
okay i think we lost ken or ken what
happened
i like this though oh [ __ ] [ __ ] that
should be
that should be an msnbc show you know
any like right after battle you know
and then she has to like you know give
them the transition into oh [ __ ] [ __ ] so
you know she's babbling to the camera
russia russia russia trump trump trump
coming up next on oh [ __ ] [ __ ] we're
screwed everybody i think that would
actually be i would watch msnbc
if that would happen i would watch msnbc
all right people i got a crazy day ahead
so i gotta jump i'm on dana perino in
about 10 minutes on fox news so you can
check that out
and uh i was just on oam this morning we
got a couple other interviews
uh and then we're going to be doing a
live direct message
from dallas on thursday and a couple
other surprises on the way
so check it out and as always if you
want to communicate with me directly
don't trust the big tech overlords
join us at my locals community at
rubinreport.com
have a great day everybody the adventure
continues
we'll be back tomorrow